to me in retrospect the black album is a
breakthrough album the band was never
more musical it's a mind-blowing album i
guess for me like 30 years ago i was
like oh my god this is all so crazy cool
now it's all more kind of just it's so
real i think it's the right way it is
surreal there's this weird paradox of
sitting talking about
you know what did you do when you 30
years ago when you walked into the
studio to make this record it's like i'm
more interested in walking into the
studio next week to work on the next
record you know so there's this weird
juxtaposition about all that stuff about
the past but
it's [ __ ] crazy to have a record
that's this uh appreciated by so many
people the original title for the album
was married to metal
um album
that was because three of us were
getting divorced and it was that was
just a joke you guys hired this guy to
produce the black album all those years
ago bob rock that's his real name
yeah i couldn't believe it first of all
yeah it's weird like i was like how did
you find this guy bob rock because you
guys are so tight
letting anyone in and and when a guy is
named bob rocky go get this [ __ ] guy
out of here so james and i flew up to
vancouver we had a couple of the rough
demos in our pocket we met with him
hong played him a couple two three songs
remember he called it this is the
cashmere of the 90s or whatever he goes
oh my god i can't believe
metallica is doing something like this
and his
his whole thing was he felt that that
we'd never captured
what we were doing live on a record that
our records were like i said the reverse
sterile they were very much about just
execution and getting it perfect but
there was no
soul there was no vibe there was no
attitude there was no swagger there was
none of those adjectives and he said i
can do that for you
and halfway through the first song he
goes up how about changing the chords in
that chorus
and i remember we all looked at each
other going excuse me like who the [ __ ]
are you somebody
how did you get in here uh do you how do
you dare suggest that we changed
anything in any of our songs we had that
was so foreign did you punch him james
no good for you
wasn't worth it
and we spent a year on that record here
in l.a and tumultuous times but we ended
up becoming best friends in the next
subsequent year or two and we ended up
working with him for another 15 years
first man in last man out he was there
uh running the show even
even though we didn't want it we didn't
like lars was saying earlier we knew we
needed to change but we didn't want to
so he was the guy that was helping us
bridge uh into that
uh well dr no to dr maybe man you know i
was like okay let's try it because i
mean i remember being excited to bring
my buddies in you got to hear this you
know wherever i may roam intro and blah
blah blah and they're standing there
going holy [ __ ] this is amazing and i
knew it was working